listen i want to start with a sincere
congrats on the movie i thought you guys
did such a great job david did such a
great job people are really going to
often enjoy this one
thanks start with that so i like
throwing a curveball at the beginning
for all three of you yeah it's an easy
one for all three of you uh if someone
has actually never seen anything you've
done before what is the first thing you
want them watching and why ooh from our
from our old uh library rep antoine
the full right
from the rabbit hole oh my god
should we say about what we think it
should be for other people instead of
myself no just for yourself
oh i know be so much i could
i'm going to say atlanta you should just
happy for bullet training to be honest
if anyone just thought would try and be
the first one i'd be like i'd be pretty
pleased and happy with that and that'd
be that'd be great
good one man you're getting out of that
yeah i'm gonna say atlanta just watch
atlanta like if you haven't seen atlanta
at this point you're racist so there
and i'm gonna say all my stuff because
just fantastic
just throw a dart
once you see one you want to see them
all isn't that going to see it all it's
like pokemon you got to catch up you've
seen me in cool world you will i'm
telling you right stop sleeping on cool
world man it's great
it's great i guess the cool world thing
is an ongoing joke through the junket
it has reared it's ugly head a few times
yes it's one of my favorite brad movies
and he doesn't want to believe me
he's mean
he's so mean
he's brilliant so one of the things i
don't think anyone watching this movie
will realize is you shot like 99
on a sony
culver city soundstage which is
incredible because it just shows how far
the technology has come with the led and
volume and everything else can you guys
sort of talk about the fact like how did
you pull this off what was it like
trying to make a movie like this on the
sony backlot on a sound stage uh you
bang on right because it's it's like
shooting like the old films like a
hitchcock film with rear projection but
this is with the latest technology and
it was in the heart of lockdown so uh
we're not we're not going to tokyo so
what they did was they we had several
train cars three train cars that they
could redress and swap around and
and these video walls this was what was
so amazing these they were like 20 feet
tall and and a football field long maybe
i'm exaggerating a little bit
but uh they had they'd be flashing the
trip from tokyo to kyoto so you really
felt like
you know like there was movement like we
actually had some
some of the crew who would get motion
sickness from it i thought it was
fantastic my last question for you guys
there are some really incredible action
sequences in this film which one was the
one that you're ready to tell david to
[ __ ] off
if any
i'm just joking by the way i'm joking
but you know you know what i mean yeah
we tell them that anyway so yeah we tell
them to [ __ ] off
you can honestly move it oh god
um fellas um do you know i think you
know it was amazing to have you know you
signed up for a david leech movie you
know it's quite brilliant how every one
of our characters got a moment to uh
shine in the uh in the action sequence
in this movie um you know and we're on
these confined
uh train carts so you know that
you're sort of
bouncing around the elements in there
you know and the environment really sort
of gave you that structure to uh to play
within and uh so it was great you know
um
i i really love the moment when me and
brad get that fly outside the train and
climb myself back in you know like they
really are pushing
some of the sort of the action side of
things and uh but yeah it's just a joy
it's been a joy with him you know uh
don't work with snakes
that's as simple as that don't work with
the [ __ ] snake on the train like it
just it like snakes on a plane is one
thing the snakes on the train is not
it's not the only thing not really that
[ __ ]
it's not fun dog it's not fun
thanks snakes to territory so that was a
[ __ ] off for david leech for sure
there it is thank you so much
congrats on the movie and good luck with
the rest of your speed dating
thanks steven
you